Loree Laughlin's daughters continue to
cope with their parents involvement in
the College Admission scandal Bella
Gianelli has deleted her Instagram amid
the ongoing investigation into the
alleged scam though it's unclear when it
was taken down a source tells ET that
Bella and her sister Olivia Jade knew
their parents were using a man to help
them get into USC but quote didn't
realize the extreme lengths he went to I
just want them to have that experience
and get that education and have a degree
to fall back on the fuller house star
allegedly paid half a million dollars
for her daughter's to get recruited as
athletes at USC Lori and her husband
Massimo were recently charged with money
laundering our source says the girls
thought the money was donated and going
to scholarships for crew team students I
want them to be happy so I want to be
supportive of everything they wanted to
do naturally 19 year old Olivia and 20
year old Bella are still trying to
process it all according to another ET
source Olivia blames her mother and
claims she always will she's not ready
to forgive we're told the youtuber has
been busy trying to rebuild her brand
without her parents help I don't really
care about school as you guys all know
our source add that olivia is quote
terrified she may have to testify
against her parents though and Bella's
break from social media does not come as
a surprise our source says she is quote
mortified and very hurt by all this but
has stood by her parents as for how Lori
is handling the case she has also stayed
off social media since the news of her
charges emerged
we're told the actress thought in the
end she would just get a slap on the
wrist lori has since pleaded not guilty
to the charges brought against her after
rejecting an initial plea deal quote she
is putting all her trust in her team and
her lawyers and hoping for the best
according to our source
[Music]